so um you also started pole dancing yes
i'm talking about this so
how are the lessons going the lessons
are going slow
but it's go they're going because
well danielle hawkins who is also my
pole dancer she also pole dances with
skates on by the way yeah
but she always the moves that she has me
doing i'm like girl i got arthritis and
that part of my leg
and then she's inflammation it ain't you
the inflammation but she'll say like now
we're going to bring our legs up and i
go with what muscles
i ain't got that so i'm i'm going
through but
it works your abs your core your arms
muscles didn't even know you had
muscles you didn't even know you had
dude i tried once
and this hotel randomly had a pole in it
look it was a bunch of people wasn't
freaky like that but there's nothing
wrong with it you won't be freaking like
that
but i just mean i tried one and i it the
loudest
it was just like it was like and this
was when i was in shape and
i got on it and just boof oh right wait
what i was like
you tried too hard i'm gonna tell you i
went and did a movie in vancouver for a
lifetime
and i brought you can take the pole with
you i have a pole in my bedroom wait
it's a travel pole yes it's travel pole
i have it in my bedroom jeffrey came in
the room he said
i wouldn't have my daughter doing this
and i was just like what
so this is in canada but i didn't put it
up right
and so the asbestos all fell from the
ceiling in my mouth
but it was so funny to see the canadian
police because they were like what is
this and i said it's my
poll and they said what do you what is
it for and i said it's when i dance
and they going why are you here i said
i'm doing a movie
so i think they thought i was doing a
porno it was all right my god
oh my god i love that explanation to
people showing up
it's my dance phone that's amazing yep
i'm still here
just waiting for you to subscribe if you
don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever
help